[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com I know that what I'm about to
ask you to do is sort of difficult to do
because it's exploding in our faces
every single day but imagine just for a
second if you can and this will be easy
for some people in our audience that
there were no Russia story right imagine
that there were no investigations into
Donald Trump no indictment no attempt to
obstruct the investigation by firing all
sorts of people put the entire thing
aside for a moment which again I think a
lot of people in our audience will
actually not have trouble doing but some
of you will we've now learned about a
completely separate Trump campaign
scandal which has exploded in the last
24 hours because of a really really good
investigation published by Britain's
channel 4 and the company in question
here is Cambridge analytic
that's not Cambridge Massachusetts right
near our studio but that's Cambridge UK
and they also play a role in today's
major breaking story about Facebook
which we'll get to later on in the
program
Cambridge analytic O'Call z' themselves
a big data behavioural micro targeting
political campaign support firm at least
that's what they call themselves on
Twitter and what they do it turns out is
a combination of opposition research and
social media targeting along with we
have now learned blackmail scams bribes
the hiring of prostitutes to set up
honey traps as well as perpetuating fake
news the Channel 4 documentary which you
should absolutely watch first part is
out about 20 minutes I believe a second
part is upcoming the documentary exposes
their techniques and it goes all the way
up to the top and when I say all the way
up to the top I don't mean close to the
top or near the top I mean to the
absolute
and what channel four did is create an
undercover investigation where they had
a an individual posing as a sri lankan
who was working with a family in Sri
Lanka and the family had aspirations for
political office in Sri Lanka and what
they wanted to meet with Cambridge
analytic to do was to sort of interview
Cambridge analytical to see if we want
to run if our family member wants to run
for elected office in Sri Lanka could
you help us what would you be able to do
in order to help us and after just a
couple of initial meetings the fake
possible client which was really an
undercover investigator working with
Channel four ends up meeting with none
other than the head of Cambridge
analytic a Alexander Nicks and Alexander
Nicks is a guy who is a public figure he
has spoken at conferences all around the
world about just the amazing and great
things that Cambridge analytic it does
and he gets caught on hidden camera in
this channel for investigation talking
about how his firm has lots of
experience bringing in prostitutes to
set up politicians he specifically
suggests the idea of Ukrainian
prostitutes as a possible as possible
agents of help with this Sri Lankan
campaign he talks about what Cambridge
analytic AHA's done how they are experts
in this stuff his co-conspirator in the
image we're showing our television
audience now sitting to Nyx's right
talking about how they are masters of
disguise in doing this type of thing and
this is yet another story that connects
directly to the Oval Office and to Jared
Kushner and to Steven Bannon who at one
point was a part owner of Cambridge
analytic a stake holder in Cambridge
analytic ah this company was Donald
Trump's campaign consultants for 2016
and this raises a whole new and separate
specter of suspicion on Donald Trump's
campaign so now if you want you can
totally disregard the Russia story not
that it's going away I just mean if
you're thinking about how Trump won you
can temporarily put aside all of the
Russia
and now we have to explore whether
Donald Trump won at least in part
because of the actions of a firm that
uses prostitutes and blackmail and
entrapment and bribe so here's how this
is going to go it's already happening to
some degree Cambridge analytic I will
deny using these tactics in their work
for Trump
they'll also deny it more broadly but
I'll get to that in a second
Trump and his team will say listen we
did some work with Cambridge analytic it
was very minor it was just social media
targeting and that's it we will all be
incredibly skeptical and hopefully
investigative journalists will start
digging into the detail about exactly
which tactics Cambridge analytic I did
use to help Donald Trump in his 2016
campaign and it might come out that yeah
Cambridge analytic I merely did some
Facebook targeting for Trump with some
of that data that they got from Facebook
which we'll talk about later today it
might come out that Cambridge analytic
Adhan 'old Trump but what is without
question is that this is one of the
biggest corporate embarrassments in a
long time and it's clear that Cambridge
analytic is clueless about how to
respond to this because their top people
are on video admitting to this stuff
watch the 19 or 20 minute documentary
and you will see Alexander Knicks and
Turnbull mark Turnbull or I forget his
first name Turnbull who is the the co
partner there the other partner talking
about all the things they have done and
can do and would suggest doing so let's
now go through some of the responses and
defenses from Cambridge analytic ah
which are just the best I'm I'm
relishing truly seeing this stuff first
this one's sort of minor the official
Twitter account for Cambridge analytic
sent out a tweet about the Channel 4
documentary where they said tonight's
Channel 4 News story gives a highly
misleading picture of the company and
what we do yeah it's misleading because
not only do they hire prostitutes for
honey traps and create blackmail videos
they'll also give you advice about how
to run Google ads so yeah that wasn't
really made a big part of the Channel 4
investigation should have been included
in the interest of full disclosure
next Cambridge analytic a floats the
idea that it was all a joke about hiring
prostitutes that the mention of the
hiring prostitutes was a way to figure
out whether their potential sri lankan
client had bad intentions they were
trying to see is the sri lankan client
immoral because we would never do any of
this stuff we were trying to suss it out
here's a quote from the statement that
Cambridge analytic about that this is
just have the barf bags nearby please
they said despite this clear statement
the undercover reporter later attempted
to entrap it's all projection Cambridge
analytic entraps and now they're saying
someone else tried to entrap them
attempted to entrap Cambridge analytic
executives by initiating a conversation
about unethical practices after several
meetings discussing ostensibly
legitimate projects the reporter
unexpectedly and suddenly turned the
conversation towards practices such as
corruption and the entrapment of
political figures assessing the legality
and reputational risks associated with
new projects is critical for us and we
routinely undertake conversations with
prospective clients to try to tease out
any unethical or illegal intentions that
is just the best and then they go on to
say the to Cambridge analytic executives
at the meeting humored these questions
and actively encourage the prospective
client to disclose his intentions it's
just a lie I mean if you watch the 20
minute documentary you will see that the
questions from the undercover reporter
are so general like can you tell me
about the type of opposition research
that you do and the CA people the
Cambridge analytical people volunteer
there's opposition research but there's
more than opposition research they
volunteer all of the stuff and the idea
that they were merely trying to suss out
and were humoring and testing out the
undercover reporter is ridiculous and
case in point within just a few meetings
they bring along their top guy Alexander
Nix the head of the company Cambridge
analytical reportedly has according to
crunch base between 100 and 250
employees
when they suspect the client of maybe
pulling their leg or having bad
intentions they send in their CEO the
top guy to meet directly with this
person who on earth would believe this
explanation and the bigger concern is
not mean listen these people are
horrible right this is this is not
democracy this is a perversion of the
democratic system and the big picture
here is that it connects directly to
Trump and right-wing media is ignoring
that connection it connects to Steven
Bannon because he held a stake he was
part owner in Cambridge analytic until
he started working for the Trump
Organization a trumpet campaign Trump
administration and sold his stake in cà
although very very late and according to
reports it also appears that it was
Jared Kushner who wanted to hire this
firm in the first place and it just so
happens that Kushner's family has a
history of entrapping people with sex
jared krishna's father Charles Kushner
hired a prostitute
to sleep with his sister's husband and
then used it as leverage against him and
it just so happens that Jared Kushner
wants to hire a company that we now know
engages in similar practices this is a
whole new scandal right it is a whole
new scandal in the Trump administration
right-wing media is going way out of its
way to keep this out of the headlines
check this out from this morning I just
said let's just see what's going on in
different right-wing news websites
Drudge Report you go there Jared and the
prince
you see stories about just about
everything other than this major major
story go to Fox news.com
what do you see another blast rocks
Texas not that that's not a story we're
gonna be talking about that story
tomorrow and all sorts of other stuff
but not this you go to Ben Shapiro's
right-wing news website daily wire
package which shrapnel explodes a Texas
FedEx facility will Germany block Israel
from finally getting a seat on the UN
progressive groups looking to organize
march in support of louis farrakhan
palestinian terrorist murder three young
jews Abbas silent but nothing about this
major major story and I could go on with
other examples it's like it just doesn't
exist
and this is ultimately the problem
because of the filter bubbles and the
echo chambers and the algorithms tons of
people will never hear about this or by
the time they do they'll inherently
assume if I haven't heard about this
until now it must not really be a big
story that is one of the biggest
problems here that this putting aside
everything else that's going on in
connection with the Trump administration
right now this is a major new scandal
and so many people will never hear about
it and if they do it'll be half-baked
harebrained attempt to debunk the entire
story but there's no debunking and the
flaccid attempts from Cambridge
analytical to say oh it's all misleading
and we were just testing them if we were
just joking about all the stuff it's BS
and I hope somehow it gets through to
the committed trumpet although quite
frankly I'm not super optimistic about
that send me your thoughts about this
story or any other from today I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman
the show is on twitter at david pakman
show the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new member of the day
is edith Hammonds
Edith thank you thank you for supporting
the program and today's sustaining
member of the day is Gary Walborn who's
been with us since 2011 almost 7 years
of membership for Gary I can't thank our
new members like Edith and our
sustaining members like Gary enough you
can join them at 40% off using the
coupon code vote soon 18 at david
pakman.com slash membership and patreon
contributions also welcome at
patreon.com forward slash david pakman
show we are in the throes of one of the
biggest tech privacy scandals in a very
long time it's now apparent that the
data analytics firm cambridge analytical
which worked for the Trump campaign we
learned over the last 24 hours based on
a channel 4 report that they engage in
everything from the hiring of
prostitutes to blackmail setups and
entrapment in order to work for their
clients Cambridge analytic working for
the Trump campaign in the most recent
presidential election inappropriately
gained access to the data of 50 million
Facebook users the data of those 50
million users ended up in the hands of
Cambridge analytic and according to some
reports has not been deleted
Cambridge analytic says that they don't
have the data it's unclear Facebook
saying we've asked them to delete it but
they haven't and a completely different
story being told by CA when I heard that
please delete it reminds me of when
Hillary went to Wall Street and told
them hey you've got to cut it out right
I'm sure they'll get right on deleting
that incredibly valuable data about 50
million Facebook users and the details
of this are somewhat complex they
involve a particular app made by a
University of Cambridge lecturer called
this is your digital life all one word
note no spaces this is your digital life
the app launched in 2014 and the app
through an entity called global science
research 2
users to a survey these surveys are
common online and the survey paid them a
dollar or two and as most of these apps
do it requested access to Facebook user
information 270,000 users
went ahead and gave the app that
permission but the app was able to also
harvest information of a total of 50
million users most of whom did not give
permission like the two hundred and
seventy thousand users now this is
already bad enough but we've also
learned that the professor working on
this
Aleksander Kogan who ironically enough
might be Russian was actually working on
the behalf of strategic communication
laboratories which owns Cambridge
analytic and who was working for the
Donald Trump campaign full circle once
again Cambridge analytic ahooo is
dealing with multiple scandals at once
at this point is saying they didn't know
where the data came from that this is
all GSR and Kogan and they weren't told
exactly how they got the data and of
course if they had known how they got
the data they would have turned it down
now does anybody believe that the
company that has no problem using
prostitutes for honey traps and
blackmail and trap mint would have a
problem receiving facebook user data if
they knew where it came from having a
hard time with that
Cambridge analytic says in a statement
quote when it subsequently became clear
that the data had not been obtained by G
s are in line with Facebook's Terms of
Service Cambridge analytic deleted all
data received from GSR so that I don't
believe but the big question Cambridge
analytic aside is was Facebook complicit
and if so to what degree and the answer
is we don't know Mark Zuckerberg is now
being summoned by British officials
British elected officials the FTC
Federal Trade Commission in the United
States is starting to look into Facebook
and here's really the bottom line I hate
to break it to you and I don't think
this is going to be news to a lot of
people in our audience this is
Facebook's business model now yeah this
went further but if you listen to my
interview about a month ago six weeks
ago I don't remember exactly how long
ago with Antonio Garcia Martinez
who developed a lot of the Facebook ad
infrastructure if you read his book
chaos monkeys Facebook is fundamentally
a user data firm right it's not a social
network primarily it's not a marketer
it's not a messaging app even though it
does those things and has those features
this is a user data company and Edward
Snowden tweeted something along these
lines when the news broke saying
businesses that make money by collecting
and selling detailed records of private
lives were once plainly described as
surveillance companies they're
rebranding as social media is the most
successful deception since the
Department of War became the Department
of the defense I learned in an early
college communica munication class a
line that goes something like this if
you're not sure what the product is and
you're not paying for anything it's
probably you or another asset another
way the product is your attention what
is being bought and sold is getting your
eyeballs onto an advertisement or a
piece of content or whatever and that is
exactly what is going on here arguably
this went further and we will see to
what degree Facebook was aware of what
was going on what did happen immediately
is that Facebook's stock price dropped
when the news broke this is probably not
going to impact their bottom line
directly right advertisers advertising
with Facebook and we've advertised with
Facebook by the way are doing it because
Facebook has such great user data not
despite that reality yeah this creates a
PR problem for Facebook it's gonna make
regulators want to regulate Facebook but
it's not really a business problem until
the regulation actually hurts them for
the individual user
it's basically cost-benefit right if you
use Facebook I use Facebook Pat uses
Facebook we realize or at least I think
we would be wise to realize that our
data our preferences our likes our
friends our activity it could end up
almost anywhere is that worth it to have
Facebook and use Facebook for a lot of
people it is and there's a broader
question here
right what is the long-term impact of
companies having such accurate and
precise data about our preferences we
know that when it comes to news the
consequence of targeting at the level
that is possible is echo chambers and
algorithms that feed our biases and
increase political partisanship and that
gets me to a really important line from
Molly McHugh Molly McHugh wrote a great
article about this yesterday where she
says it doesn't matter if you don't use
your Facebook feed for politics your
Facebook feed is using you for politics
and I think that that is something we
all sort of need to be aware of here
right with products and services it's ok
well they might be able to really well
target accurately target ads so that
you'll buy stuff or sign up for services
with elections it's potentially deciding
the outcome of who our elected officials
are and thus even if you say I don't
really read news on Facebook I don't
really care about this or that I'm just
down there for the pictures or sharing
stuff with my family even if you aren't
doing politics on facebook these
algorithms are having political impact I
don't know and I wouldn't even dream of
trying to predict what is ultimately
going to happen in terms of regulation
but this is only the beginning of that
in terms of an FTC investigation and
summons from the United Kingdom of Mark
Zuckerberg and we will see where it goes
but this is this is a major major tech
privacy scandal you might have learned
the other day that Russia had a quote
election in which Vladimir Putin quote
did really well receiving quote almost
77% of the vote then we all woke up from
that total fantasy world as dozens and
dozens of videos of people literally
stuffing ballot boxes with stacks of
ballots have been released we have a ton
of videos of this the Washington Post
put one together where you can see
people just putting stacks of paper into
these ballots and of course the defense
has been well that all these individuals
might have collected a bunch of people's
ballots and put them in at once do you
see that that's how the polling place is
set up I mean where where are these
ballots coming from it makes absolutely
no
since and in order to make the absurd
77% of the vote number that Putin
supposedly received appears slightly
more mathematically believable the
opposition leader Alexei Navalny says
that the official turnout numbers were
also inflated reported as sixty seven
point five percent Navalny saying that
that's actually like ten percentage
points higher than the real turnout
again this is according to opposition
candidate Navalny seventy-seven cent
percent for Vladimir Putin the highest
ever in a Russian presidential election
now you might say to me hey David listen
stuffing ballots into ballot boxes is a
really low-tech and inefficient way to
help Putin if there was real centralized
corruption here you would do it in some
other way you're not gonna physically
send people out there to stuffed ballot
boxes well that's right but what you're
forgetting is Putin didn't need these
votes to win right I'm not saying Putin
would have lost without the ballot
stuffing what I'm saying is he wouldn't
have won by as much it would have just
been much closer I don't even know that
Putin necessarily needs to be in on this
Pat because local governments want to
please Putin the last thing you want to
be is the local official whose district
didn't have a solid turnout for Putin so
I'm not even alleging necessarily that
Vladimir Putin was directly coordinating
this but if the defenses are just
laughable oh here's one Putin's approval
rating is something like eighty one
percent eighty three percent and that's
in line with the percentage of the vote
that he got well Ben fine must have been
fine there's absolutely no problem
whatsoever one other funny video to show
you here's someone places a grew a bunch
of balloons right in front of the camera
at a polling place a woman walks over
and then just casually all of a sudden
exactly where the camera is she just
moves a bunch of balloons right in front
but this is just the best isn't it you
know you would think that at this point
we would we would want to be beyond this
type of stuff but we're not and a funny
defense of the videos is okay fine
listen David you're right it's ballot
stuffing but we don't know which
candidates supporters are stuffing the
ballots you can't say for sure
that those are Putin ballots that are
being stuffed in there give me a break
right in order to believe that these
were opposition ballots stuffings you
have to first explain how were they able
to get away with that
despite putin's cronies controlling
endless numbers of polling places and
that would also imply it but imply that
putin didn't just set a record with 77%
of the vote he arguably had even more of
the vote but because of opposition
ballot stuffing the number was
inaccurately low i mean who would
believe that stuff you've got yeah I
spend disbelief in total to believe
people are still questioning whether or
not Russia influence the US presidential
election they're doing it for their own
elections of course they are there is a
tweet that was put out by Edward Snowden
about this as well and this is twice now
that I'm quoting Edward Snowden today
and I am no a big defender of Snowden
but when he says something that I
believe is accurate I'll tell you
Snowden tweeted the ballot stuffing
scene today in Moscow and elsewhere in
the Russian election is an effort to
steal the influence of 140 million plus
people demand justice demand laws and
courts that matter take your future back
want to make one other comment about
this okay and this is a comment about
the toxic left as I'm calling it
Pat's taking feverish notes now there is
this contingent I've mentioned before of
sort of Leninist Hugo Chavez loving
so-called leftists who are saying
there's nothing to see in terms of
Russian influence in the United States
there's nothing to see in terms of
ballot stuffing in Russia either we have
irregularities here in the United States
as well so who are we to pass judgment
on what's going on in Russia's elections
have fun with that just stay away from
me I have no interest in even engaging
with you discuss this with us on our
subreddit david patten.com slash our EDD
i
coming up next I'm ready for this good
old-fashioned Exorcist stay with us
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
welcome back to the David Pakman show
here's something different that I think
you'll also find very interesting today
I'm speaking to Rachel stavis who's a
non-denominational Exorcist whose memoir
sister of darkness is out and it tells
her story of Exorcist training extreme
cases and sort of what it takes to
complete an exorcism so that I'm super
interested in this and I really
appreciate you talking to me about it
how did you even find your way into
being an exorcist well when I was a kid
you know I always like other kids
complained about seeing monsters under
the bed and monsters in the closet and
then you know parents would come in
right and check and say there's nothing
there but for me it never went away hmm
so I've actually been able to see
entities with my eyes since I was a
child I didn't really want to naturally
it was really scary and I thought that
you know everybody must be doing this
until I learned very quickly you don't
talk about it so I tried to push it away
kind of have a normal life you know
become a writer do all all the normal
things and then as I got older it became
more basically impossible to block it
out anymore and at that point I had to
make a decision what am I gonna do you
know am I gonna check myself in or am I
actually going to do something with this
and that's when I decided okay there's
there's a reason right reason for
everything so there's a reason for why I
have this and it turns out it was
exorcism and as an example what what was
something you were seeing a record or
that you see that caused this that sort
of catalyzed this well you know I didn't
really I wasn't able to categorize them
until I started getting older and
accepting the fact that I was looking at
this but I would see very similar things
over and over again so you know just to
just to kind of give some background you
know when people think about exorcism
and they think about entities or what
people call demons they kind of think of
the movies right where it's it's like
one specific kind of Dean
and they're all kind of the same and you
know you say their name and you throw
some holy water and it's gone that's not
actually how it works there it's it's
almost if you will a species of many
different species of demons there's lots
of different ones so to make a long
story short right what I was seeing look
like monsters and there are all
different kinds of them there's probably
thousands of different kinds of entities
I probably still have yet to see them
all right but or some that are really
common which people carry very often you
know it's it's not as it's not as
uncommon to have attachment as people
believed so it's very common that the
concept of a demon is associated with
not not just religion in general but
particularly jhin's now I know you're
nondenominational but is this still is
there a religious underpinning to what
you do you know hard to say well let me
put it a different way are you like for
example are you a Christian no you're
not are you Catholic
none of these things okay nominal right
but but that doesn't mean that I don't
believe and work with high being so so
let me give you some background right on
this the way that I work is really
different than probably any other
Exorcist or exorcism thing that people
have ever encountered by yeah like I
work in energy and frequency right so if
you think about it just just on a
logical level right we are all energy we
all emit an energy every single day and
the way we though I mean we're made up
of matter which has potential energy and
of course you know we consume food and
that potential energy is converted into
kinetic energy but I don't know in what
sense are we energy well so we emit
frequency every single day that's that's
something that actually you can you can
look up you know we we have energetic
frequencies that we put out into the
world in from what I work in write the
words actions we're all emitting an
energy that goes out into the world
we're carrying it with us we go through
the world a specific way and it's our
energy signature you know what we carry
and that doesn't change that much
throughout the day so if you you know
have a good day it might be a little
better if you have a bad day right
exactly and we go
how in other words what what device can
evaluate how that energy sort of changes
throughout the day and and in what
what's the scale of measurement we don't
really have that yet that's the issue so
I I work with spirit that's how I see it
so on it whether believe in that or you
don't is up to you right so I work with
spirit I work with energies I can see
these energies with my eyes so therefore
to be that exists right so it depend on
your belief system right up so so in the
day when we go out and we have this it's
pretty much the same the only time that
it changes is when we have a trauma
okay when we trauma it affects us and
our energy then dips low we have low
frequency situations that we're now
emitting that's how attachment finds us
attachment works in low frequency and
when you lo can we just define low
frequency we're talking about wave
theory and frequency is like a specific
element of wave theory are you talking
about Hertz as in sort of like an audio
wave or when you say low frequency how
is that defined so for me the way that I
see it it's almost like okay yes it's
it's like what you're saying so for me
when I look at it I can see people's how
do you define this it's not quite aura
do you know what I mean like it's it's
so you see the energy I'm curios you
called it low frequency which is nice
something that would be detected either
orally like a you are not oo-aah rare a
you are like in terms of sound but the
low frequency you actually see it
visually I see it visually and my my
vernacular where I get all these words i
work with spirit and that's that's the
information that I get when my spirits
have given you this sort of vocabulary
that you use right so in other word do
like not everyone agrees with calling
demon entity right is called an entity
sure you know not everybody will agree
with calling all of this spirit but like
I call it right so it's define it
however you like let's let's just put it
that way God for me it's the perspective
to just help you understand what I'm
seeing I think understanding yeah like
what it is and how I define it might be
diff
for other people just like people always
ask me when you see entity like the way
it shows itself to you is that how it
actually looks or is that you know
whatever and I don't have the answer for
that right I can only tell you this is
how this is how it presents itself to me
got it now Rachel let me ask you this
why do you believe that you have this
ability to do exorcism and it's sort of
related to my other question which is in
the Catholic Church it's believed that
Exorcist the skill of exorcism is a
skill that can be learned on the other
hand you have people who work more in
the psychic medium side who believe that
this is just something that you are born
with and you either have or you don't is
your skill for exorcism more on the
Catholic Church learn a skill side or is
it more on the something more ethereal
and and god-given or whatever term you
want to apply to it well you know I
think it's a little bit of both if you
really want to know like I think there's
a certain amount of like why do I have
it right I don't know I was able to
bring it to the world maybe that's why
I'm teaching people you know what this
is and and again like it's not listen
I'm not for everybody it's not for
everybody but for people who want to
receive the message they get it the
words if somebody was not sort of open
to the idea that people could be
infested by demons and that an exorcism
could cure the cure it or relieved that
what you do wouldn't be for them in
other words not necessarily although I
do also work in trauma and pain so you
know I do take that out of the body as
well and again think about something
that I see write a C and I feel so oh
how do you define that how do you
measure that's really hard to say I
can't tell you exactly how to do that
but you know if even for people who've
come to me that don't necessarily
believe that they have attachment or you
know and I've had a lot of skeptics come
through here like it's not for people
who are like I'm totally down for an
exercise I do get a lot of people who
are like I don't believe in this at all
but somebody had a good experience and
I'm desperate so let's try it right so
some people come to you out of
desperation in other words they're in
such a state that they'd be willing to
accept just anything that might give any
sign of improvement that they've sort of
gotten to gotten to that point and they
arrived for an exorcism and on that
basis absolutely I mean if you think
about it if you just think about it
going to an exorcist is everybody's last
resort this this is not the first resort
situation and right I've tried
everything I don't even know about this
really me out but I'm gonna give it a
try right it's you know what those are
my favorite people actually to take
because those are people who come in
they don't want to tell me anything
right they want to keep it all to
themselves and then they're like let's
just do this and I'm like okay let's
just do it and by the end of it they're
like in shock and in disbelief that they
feel different really different no so
and always the process of the exorcism
like and without I mean we don't need to
get into the full logistics but just so
our audience has a sense of physically
what it is that happens during an
exorcism what's that like for them or
for me well what what are you doing to
or around them okay so that goes back to
the religious question right so I'm not
religious but I do work with high beings
as above so below that's the feeling
right so if we have all these low things
that we're trying to expel then we need
to call in high things to help expel
that right and so I work with high being
so high beings meaning you know spirit
guides master teachers religious figures
you know because that's still high being
all different kinds so that people feel
comfortable so if you come to me and
you're religious you know it works for
you too because that's that's something
that I can call in for you what are you
like you call in a rabbi and he kind of
blesses it like he would matzo or no no
I mean high being like what people would
call God's with people you know in the
end of bread angels like Archangels
things like that got it ah that's what I
call it and the way that I work is I
call them into put energy through the
body so and if you're in a place of low
energy in the body and that's what's
causing that attachment we have to fill
you with the the high being energy to
pull that out to make that come out of
the body right they've got it full of it
yeah yeah
during that process you know we there's
other things that go on like there you
know I have shamanic tools that work
like rattles and things like that things
that add to Tate that energy I use
specific in senses and burns that blends
the space and cleanse the energy is it a
lavender persimmon one of the ones you
use or are there like specific ones that
are exorcism approved no we're talking
about things like copal frankincense
even sometimes things like Blue Lotus
little Spain like bloom pretty yeah some
of it's fairly hardcore yeah right so
and then how long does this thing take
or last you know it depends on the
entity like I said there are many
different kinds some are more malevolent
and more difficult to remove than others
so some people carry what I call a
trickster which is something that
creates a symbiotic relationship with
the host that you know sometimes kids
will get that when when they're young
and it'll be something that's an
imaginary friend a genie and deceased
level on an angel yeah and oftentimes
those create you know something that
that is hard to take out right right
they Teknik want it but then there are
some that people have that are just kind
of like leeches like amplifiers of
emotions kind of make things worse and
those are pretty simple to take out so
it could go anywhere from 45 minutes to
several days that is the is the charge
the cost of this different depending on
whether it's a 45 minute in or out or
like a several day session well I don't
charge for it you don't charge at all no
no I so how do you know how do you make
a living how do you pay for the space
where these these are these events are
taking place I'm a screenwriter I've
been a writer for many many years onto
say 15 years now
yeah regularly are you just cut out
there for a second Rachel you said for
15 years you've been a screenwriter
right yes yes so I I make a good living
I don't I don't charge people for my
services there because I I actually
believe that whenever because you know
look I work on people who are very very
wealthy you know studio heads
icons all of these things yeah and I
also work on people who have very little
so I like to have everyone come in here
as equal this is an equal place we're
not we're no different in here amazing
well let's pause there just briefly
we're speaking with non-denominational
Exorcist Rachel Stavis and we'll
continue our conversation with her
momentarily the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
Attorney General Jeff Sessions our buddy
might have committed perjury again
remember that Jeff Sessions just fired
deputy FBI director Andrew McCabe for in
part this is just so funny lack of
candor during testimony we already know
that back in March of 2017 in a hearing
Jeff sessions said he had no
communication with Russians during the
Trump campaign we later learned that he
actually had multiple communications
with Russians this was the first live
from this sort of series of lies of
course there are lots of other Jeff
Sessions lies unrelated to this series
but just as a reminder this is how that
went down when being questioned by Al
Franken and if there is any evidence
that anyone affiliated with the Trump
campaign communicated with the Russian
government in the course of this
campaign what will you do senator
Franken I'm not aware of any of those
activities I have been called a
surrogate at a time or two in that
campaign and I did not have
communications with the Russians and I'm
unable to comment on total lie
probably perjury he'll never get in
trouble for it though fill the swamp and
move on okay we thought we were done and
beyond it but sessions testified again a
couple of times including in November of
2017 and that time it was before the
House Judiciary Committee and it appears
that sessions also lied during that
hearing he was asked about now indicted
Trump advisor George papadopolis
Papadopoulos had proposed that Donald
Trump's campaign reach out to Russia
during that meeting that took place on
March 31st of 2016
Trump was at that meeting sessions was
at that meeting other top top Trump
staff were at that meeting sessions
claimed during the testimony that he
pushed back against them that he thought
reaching out to Russia was a bad idea
and that he wanted to make sure
everybody in the room knew that he
thought it was a bad idea unfortunately
it appears that that was also a lie
because Reuters is now reporting that
three people who were at the meeting
said now it's not true sessions
expressed no objection whatsoever to
reaching out to Russia and these three
individuals say they've also
spoken to Robert molars investigators
and told Robert molars team that it
wasn't true what Jeff sessions said he
posed no objection whatsoever to
reaching out to Russia now there is I
want to be thorough I'm not hiding
anything from you there's a fourth
person who is at the meeting who says no
no Jeff sessions is telling the truth he
did push back so currently it's three to
one on this issue we can think about who
to believe right do we believe the
recused Attorney General who's already
been caught lying or do we believe the
three people who were in the room and
were interviewed by Robert Moeller's
team and said no sessions didn't push
back at George papadopolis suggestion
that we reach out to Russia you judge
for yourself who you want to believe but
the really depressing part of all of
this is that no one's gonna go after
sessions for perjury right there have
been no consequences for sessions lies
back from March of 2017
there have been no consequences for
sessions for recusing himself on
anything related to Russia and then
firing people specifically to interfere
with the Russia investigation as
admitted by Donald Trump they currently
control every aspect of the government
they seem to be unable to control robert
muller which is good right like we hope
that they're not controlling robert
muller and that that investigation will
happen fully and fairly but we're not
gonna see anybody within trump's
administration hold jeff Sessions
accountable here for recusing and then
being involved and then lying once
during testimony to the Senate and once
during testimony at least once during
testimony to the house Trump could
remove sessions for the lies yeah right
and also we could argue that firing
sessions in a way might be a step
towards firing Muller but I think Pat we
just have to come to terms with the
reality that there's not going to be a
repercussion sessions for having done
this it's not gonna happen and
unfortunately I think sessions view of
in the public has been tarnished I agree
for a time even though we had
disagreements with him he could be seen
as a patriot because he did decide to
recuse himself he's not a complete
Lackey for Trump and it looked like he
wasn't willing to make those contacts
with Russia now we don't know what to
believe yet there was a period of about
three and a half minutes that Pat's
referring to where we had Plaza
belief of what Jeff sessions said before
it was instantly fact-check and realized
he was lying I mean let no it was longer
than three and a half minutes but you're
right like bye and it's not that I would
call him a patriot but yeah but you're
saying as a straight and standard by the
standards of the committed trumpets
which are shifting standards by the way
you could sort of say like this guy is
not the worst guy out there but yeah
that's gone out the window and there
we're gonna have to just realize that
hopefully some people will be held
accountable for this entire thing that
is being investigated but we're gonna
have to come to terms with the reality
that a lot of them just or not they're
not going to be held accountable and
it's sad I don't know what else to tell
you I wish I had something else I could
say a word of inspiration but I don't
the topic of abstinence only sex
education is resurfacing as a
conservative Republican priority in the
Trump era which is just hilarious
because of the number of sex scandals
related to Trump which directly
contradict the concept of just
abstaining from sex and also opposition
to birth control and historically the
right has had this totally illogical
position on this issue which is that
they don't want abortions but they want
to teach abstinence only sex education
instead of comprehensive sex ed with
access to affordable contraceptives and
the reason that it's incoherent is that
we know that abstinence only sex ed
doesn't work right it leads to more
pregnancy and when you have more people
getting pregnant without wanting to be
pregnant
that increases the demand for abortion
so that's the general idea but now we're
hearing from the conservatives in the
Department of Health and Human Services
that they are now under trump shifting
back to pushing abstinence only sex
education and they're just super excited
and the way that it's working is that
under Title 10 title 10 has been around
since Nixon it's a federal grant that
gives money to programs for family
planning and preventive health services
and the idea that the Trump DHHS is
using is when they get title ten
requests they are encouraging the
recipients to push abstinence only sex
education if they want the money and the
funny and really sad part is that as
this is happening we're getting more and
more data
from when President Obama was president
and under Obama we had a focus not on
abstinence but we had a focus on
comprehensive sex ed access to birth
control we saw a decline in teen
pregnancy in other words as we are
learning the obvious reality that the
Obama approach reduced teen pregnancy
we are seeing the trump dhhs go back to
let's push abstinence only education
which we know doesn't work and not only
doesn't it work but the hypocrisy of the
Trump administration promoting this is
just laughable did Trump use
contraception with stormy Daniels to
prevent pregnancy if so how can the
administration credibly teach something
different and the answer is the results
don't matter the results have never
mattered I've spoken to you about this
term strict father morality for a very
long time even if you make the logical
case to a conservative that hey your
goal is reduce abortion to do that we've
got to reduce unwanted pregnancy the way
to reduce unwanted pregnancy is access
to birth control and comprehensive sex
education and you would think it would
be an obvious yes to the conservative
but the strict father moralist of the
Religious Right says now because what
you're doing is you are giving license
for a recreational non-procreative sex
outside of marriage and really the
priority is to prevent that not to
actually reduce the number of
pregnancies which reduces the number of
abortions and once you understand that a
lot of right-wing policy actually makes
a lot more sense we have a voicemail
number that number is two one nine to
david p here's a nice little question
from the audience let's take a listen i
love answering these questions uh yeah i
was wondering if you support communism
which is basically social anarchism
based on common ownership of the means
of production yeah with money being
abolished that's all that's all I do not
support communism I do not and why do
you think we get asked so often whether
I support communism like I feel like
every time this comes up I say I am a
supporter of well regulate
elated capitalist economies sort of like
the Scandinavian models that we see and
yet
maybe it's my suits maybe it's my hair I
don't know what it is but I constantly
am answering this question or am i a
socialist am i a communist I'm not yeah
I mean how does a caller watch the show
every day see us talk about politics and
economics and all of these different
topics and come away with it thinking
that maybe you are a commie I really
don't have to call in just to make sure
it's the frequency with which we get
that question is stunning to me and if
somebody can explain it to me I it's
it's not because I'm Jewish is it right
like I don't I don't even want to open
up that door because that's another
thing like the stereotypical Jewish
communist and I think you wear a red
shirt on the program I know I don't even
think I own a red shirt nevermind wear a
red shirt on the program please tell me
why it is that so many people think I
might be a communist all right we've got
a great bonus show for you today I don't
even have time to tell you what's on it
but trust me it's a good one access it
by becoming either a member or a patron
and we will speak to you
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
you